what are the future trajectories that
lead to a potential war with China cold
war or hot war is this something you
think about is this something you're
worried about yeah I'd like to talk
about both Wars so the war with China
as I said there are five kinds of Wars
there's a trade war tech technology War
geopolitical influence War
um Capital war and military war I
um as far as military war goes I only I
think it's only a Taiwan issue
um but that's a big issue and we could
talk about that for a minute but those
others they'll be rough competitions
um and we'll have that type of evolution
over a period of time that's what that
war looks like Taiwan has been
for a long time
um a sovereignty issue to China
um and it has its roots in What's called
the Hundred Years of humiliation
um from the 1840s to 1949 foreign powers
came in took advantage of China they had
the Opium Wars in such times
um and that represented the 100 Years of
humiliation and Taiwan
um represents is their sovereignty and
their their important thing and 50 years
ago starting 50 years ago there was an
agreement that there is one China and
Taiwan is part of China and that there
would be peaceful reunification
the the peaceful reunification hasn't
happened and in their view that's a very
big issue and so it's a big contentious
issue and that uh could produce a
military war
um could produce a military accident
could produce it's a very tense
situation and if we had a military war
God help us because of the capacity in
all different new ways to inflict
um harm on each other but anyway that's
that's that if you don't have that
military war you'll have the competition
between those other kinds of wars and
whoever is strongest in those areas will
win
where do you put cyber War within the
five well cyber war is a military war
I'm I'm assuming the type of cyber war
that you're you you're referring to is
that which it's used to inflict pain on
the other party through cyber so Cyber
Wars you'll see cyber War you could see
space War you can see drone Warfare
you um new types of warfare not just
um the traditional and and nuclear type
of warfare but you could see any of the
above